I didn't tackle the second one first
this one's in the vertex form and you
can see that's the a times X minus H
squared plus K form HK is the vertex you
can see the vertex is going to be a 3-1
okay so it's the opposite this is the
same okay as the science opposite sign
same sign and the 1/2 that tells us that
it's going to be compressed by 1/2 so we
can look at the parent function y equals
1/2 x squared I'm just going to plot
some values if X is let's say 2 2
squared is 4 times 1/2 is 2 if we pick
let's say 4 that's going to be 16 times
1/2 is 8 so if we plot a couple points
here from the vertex we've got 2 2 so
I'm going right 2 up to and you can also
go the other direction okay and I could
also go right for up 8 let's see 1 2 3 4
up 8 let's see that's going to be 1 2 3
4 5 6 7 8 ok just right about there and
right about let's see 1 2 3 4 right
about there
okay now notice how this is greater than
or equal to that means it's going to
include the points on the graph so this
is a solid line it's not - ok it
includes the points on this ok
approximately like that
ok now the next thing I want to do is
want to shade so Y is greater than means
we're gonna shade above so greater than
means see if we pick a point on the
parabola greater than because Y controls
the vertical Direction up and down
greater they're going to shade straight
up okay
we're shading straight above like so
okay if it was less than we would shade
below the graph down okay now the second
one this one's in the general form okay
and you can see to find the vertex here
you're gonna use that formula x equals
negative B over 2a so this is our a
value this is our B value this is our C
value so negative B would be the
opposite of 6 which is positive 6 over 2
times 3 which is also 6 so that comes
out to 1 now if we put one back in for X
we can solve for the y coordinate the
vertex so that's going to be 1 squared
is 1 times 3 is 3 minus 6 times 1 is
just negative 6 ok plus 1 so that's
negative 3 plus 1 is negative 2 okay so
it looks like our vertex here is at 1
negative 2 and let's see if we want to
look at the parent function y equals 3 x
squared we can do it
on that we get 1/3 and 212 well case I'm
just putting one in for axle what I'm
going to do is from this point I'm going
to go right one up three one two three
okay and I can do the same thing on the
other side since its symmetric and then
212 let's see so that's going to be 1/2
way up here ok and then let's see over
here let's see 2 that's going to be 1/2
way up here ok so basically this one is
greater than but not equal to so what we
have here is we have a dashed ok line ok
so it's going to look something like
let's see something like this ok
approximately now greater than means
we're shading above so above means that
I'm going to be shading any point on the
graph on to be shading straight up like
this but you know in this case I'm just
going to draw the lines this way just to
help us to visualize it a little bit
better so greater than if shading above
and you can see where there crosshatch
okay where they overlap that's the
solution set so it looks like it's going
to be right in here ok is where they're
overlapping and that's how you approach
it now I could have been a little bit
more precise with my graph like for
example I could have found the
y-intercept by setting X to 0 that would
have been a good additional point I
could have also just plotted additional
points besides the ones I just did here
but the main point I wanted to point out
is if it's greater then your shading
above the graph less than your shading
below if it's equal to it's a solid line
if it's not equal to just like less than
or greater than it's gonna be a dashed
line and the idea is to find out where
those parabolas overlap so if you want
to check out more about graphing
quadratics you can go to my Mario's math
tutor youtube channel and find out more
about the different forms whether it's
vertex form slope intercept
I'm sorry vertex form the general form
or the intercept form and subscribe to
the channel check out some more videos
again like I said on my mario's math
tutor youtube channel and i look forward
to seeing in the future videos I'll talk
to you soon